The year was 1991. It was a quiet
night in Lethargy Valley, Arizona,
the quietest town in all of Maricopa County.
Seriously, despite the hardcore Arizona dry heat,
this is one of the most idyllic little towns
you could imagine. Everyone who lived there knew
each other by name and regularly invited their
neighbors to wholesome neighborhood cookouts. The
town’s historic main street had an old-fashioned
ice cream parlor, a knitting supplies store,
and even a Build-A-Bear workshop. And of course,
a few local car dealerships and auto body shops.
Lethargy Valley really is just the sweetest,
calmest place you can possibly imagine,
and tonight, my friends, it’s going to rock.
While the citizens of Lethargy Valley
went about their evening duties,
something hardcore was heading their way, rumbling
across the scorching Arizona deserts, burning fuel
and belching smog. The hottest hot rods this side
of the sun. Wheels so fly they’re ready to take
off, with riders so badass their own reflections
are scared of them. That’s right: These are
the High-Octane Full-Throttle Adventures of the
Exploding Zombie Gearheads, and they’re about to
give this sleepy Arizona town a Four-Loko enema.
The sun was setting on Lethargy Valley when the
lights of distant fire cut through the night.
Citizens and shopkeepers, enjoying an evening
summer breeze, halted in town as the redness in
the East got closer and brighter. They could feel
the rumble of torqued-up subwoofers rattling
the ground. The roar of the engines felt more
fitting on 747s than road-legal cars. And when
the distance was close enough that they could
taste the vapors of burning gasoline in the
air, they could finally hear the laughter, too.
Meet SCP-3885-01, also known as
the Exploding Zombie Gearheads,
probably the most metal of all anomalies on
the SCP Foundation catalog. But let’s talk
about the time before these gas-chugging dust
devils were just another number in The Man’s
filing cabinet. Cause these bad boys don’t care
about filing - They only care about defiling.
They rolled into Lethargy Valley like a
pack of easy-riding coyotes on gearhead
steroids. Their skin is green from rot, and
covered in cuts, lesions, and gnarly burn scars.
Some have their heads completely cracked open,
exposing what little brains they have underneath.
Others have fully opened rib cages and
disemboweled bellies. But they don’t care.
These ain’t your grandpa’s zombies. Forget the
Walking Dead, these dudes are the Riding Dead.
Romero meets Ratfink after ten lines of
Columbian Bam-Bam and a gallon of Monster
Energy drink, decked out in a patchwork of
Motorhead-style leather and stolen clothes.
And you better believe these fun-dead
freakazoids are here to party hardy.
Paulie Poundtown rounded the corner of Main street
first on his ride, The Murderlizer. In a past
life, it’d been a coffin, but now, with the aid of
two monster truck wheels on the back and a pair of
circular saw blades on the front, it was a vehicle
ready to tear up the streets. Literally. Paulie
drove down the road at a break-neck pace, leaving
a trail of sparks and black smog behind him.
He was screaming something about being king of the
world when the vehicle exploded underneath him.
The force of the boom flung Paulie down the
length of the street. He hit the window of a
local barbershop and shattered through it like a
fleshy missile. For a moment, he lay on the tiles,
a leather pincushion of broken glass and
wooden shrapnel from the recently-detonated
Murderlizer. But at no moment in this
whole insane ordeal did Paulie stop
laughing. He got up, noticing his neck was
twisted backward at an odd angle - we told
you it was a break-neck pace - but Paulie
just grabbed that sucker and crunched it
back into place. It’d take a little more than
a totaled spine to stop Paulie Poundtown.
After all, the night’s fun was only just starting.
More tricked-out zombie roadsters were
pouring into the town from every angle,
hopped up on a combination of tequila, lighter
fluid, and some stuff we can’t even mention
if we want to keep monetization on this video.
Steely Dan was roaring into the Build-A-Bear
workshop on a modified toilet with all-crushing
caterpillar tracks. Once he’d busted in through
the facade, he dismounted his porcelain throne
and began incinerating walls of teddy bears
with a custom flamethrower powered by
a tube going into his stomach cavity.
Once he was done burning 90% of the bears in
the store, he used the remaining unsullied
parts to make a grungy-looking bear in his
own likeness. He strapped it to the front
of his terrifying mobile toilet, and then
burnt that, too, just for the fun of it.
Bareback Boris was making a beeline for the
ice cream parlor, riding what would look like
a bull to the untrained eye. It was actually
a taxidermied bull, gutted and filled with a
nightmarish configuration of motorcycle parts
that would function better together as a method
of execution than a workable vehicle, but that’s
just how the Exploding Zombie Gearheads like it.
Boris pulled the handbrake, which
was made out of some old bones he dug
up once, and ground the Bullcycle to a
screeching halt in front of the parlor.
He climbed off and kicked in the door,
before running in to cause some chaos.
Boris, the animal that he was, grabbed handfuls
of gelato and shoved them into his mouth, before
turning and spitting them at the wall. He pulled
out a bottle of 90% vodka and took a long swig,
before taking a court summons out of his
jacket and shoving it into the bottle.
He lit the top of the litigious fuse with
his lighter, which was shaped like a knife,
and made a molotov cocktail. Moments
later, the whole store was in flames.
Boris stepped out of the burning ice cream
parlor, on fire but utterly unphased. He
pulled out no less than four cigars
and lit them on his own burning skin,
before smoking each one in a single
pull. If his lungs didn’t already look
like blackened lumps of decaying coal,
they would have been screaming at him.
But right now, the only person screaming
was Gene Simmons of the band KISS,
as some of Boris’ fellow riders rampaged through
the streets past him, “UNHOLY” blaring from their
radios at ear-exploding volumes. The Exploding
Zombie Gearheads didn’t throw out-of-town ragers
like this often, but when they did, they always
tried to make it one for the history books. And
before you start worrying about the safety of the
citizens of Lethargy Valley, Arizona, you should
know that the Zombie Gearheads never hurt anybody.
Well, never hurt anybody on purpose, that is.
If a piece of stray shrapnel from an exploding
Camaro, reshaped with scrap metal to look like
a giant fist spraying fire from its knuckles,
happens to take out somebody’s eye, well...That
can’t really be seen as anybody’s fault, can
it? Especially when you don’t have eyes anymore.
The closest thing to the brains of this operation
- which, for these guys, really isn’t saying
much - was a free-thinking, free-spirited,
free-liquored individual known as Joey
nuts. The whole gang had probably
about 40 brain cells between them,
but at least five of those cells belonged to
Joey. While many of his rotting buddies were
goofing off and causing mayhem across town,
Joey was already acting on the real reason
everybody was here: Getting new parts
for their sick-as-all-hell car mods.
Sure, as mechanics, they couldn’t produce
actually workable vehicles worth a damn.
But at the end of the day, isn’t a vehicle
looking awesome much more important than
boring old functionality? If you think
otherwise, you’re probably just a square.
But we digress, back to Joey nuts. Joey and
a crew of his boys - including Dirty Mike,
Scuzzy Steve, and Generally Unclean Gary - rolled
up on one of the local auto body shops and bashed
the door down with their vehicle. Which,
by the way, was a modified SUV modded with
bulldozer parts and a makeshift cannon. It was
a powerful, if structurally unsound, motorized
siege weapon. Joey and the boys jumped off
the vehicle and stormed into the building,
wielding pipe wrenches with nails
and fishing hooks welded onto them.
A confused mechanic was quaking in his boots as
the gaggle of zombie gearheads approached him.
Joey stood at the front, swinging his pipe
wrench around with menacing randomness.
He was chewing twelve toothpicks,
making him look extra tough.
The mechanic, with a quiet, trembling voice,
told Joey and the boys that they needed to leave.
They weren’t supposed to be back here.
They’d need to leave and come back during
opening hours. It was the most polite
telling-off he could possibly muster.
The exploding zombie gearheads just
laughed. Once they were done cackling,
Joey lifted up his pipe wrench and pointed it
at the terrified mechanic’s face. Joey cleared
his tobacco-and-gasoline-burned throat and said:
“Listen, ya stupid grease monkey, I’m only
gonna say this once so open your earholes
real wide and listen up, ‘kay? You’re gonna
pack up your crap and leave, so me and my boys
can loot this place to our heart’s content, and
beef up our sick-ass rides. And if you don’t
leave? You’re gonna be holding this here pipe
wrench for me in your prison pocket. You get me?”
The mechanic definitely got him. He didn’t
waste a moment in high-tailing it out of
the store while Joey and the boys pulled
a classic “smash and grab” on his wares.
They stole everything from whole cars
to wrenches and lug nuts. Across town,
the Exploding Zombie Gearheads were doing the
exact same thing: Stealing or stripping every
vehicle in sight and cannibalizing the parts
for their own righteous whips. Town by town,
vehicle by vehicle, explosion by explosion, they’d
one day figure this whole “mechanic” deal out.
With the night’s revelry finally concluded, it was
time to return home and get to work on the next
set of rides. This legion of awesome, unkillable
morons piled back into their stylish death traps,
and rode off into the misty dawn, leaving
hundreds of thousands of dollars in property
damage behind them - But not a single
death. As hyper-destructive anomalies go,
they’re honestly pretty benevolent. Or at
least, too self-centered to be truly malevolent.
They tore up the desert on the way back
to the real SCP-3885: Vulture Gulch,
the home of the Exploding Zombie Gearheads.
It’s a desert shantytown that’s “officially”
been abandoned since July 9th, 1973, due to high
volumes of dangerous radon gas being emitted from
the uranium deposits in a nearby mine. But these
intense, joy-riding mutants hardly mind a little
bit of radiation in their sweet pad. Be it ever
so radioactive, there’s no place like home, right?
Some of the vehicles even exploded
on the way back to the place,
but the boys didn’t mind. The flaming explosion
survivors just crawled out of the fire and hopped
onto the rides of their closest buddies. All
in all, everyone in attendance had a damn good
time that night. They’d spend the rest of the
early morning setting rocks on fire for fun
and chewing on ignited fireworks. That’s the
kind of brain trust we’re dealing with here.
When the Foundation eventually
contained them in Vulture Gulch,
the gearheads didn’t even put up a fuss,
as long the Foundation kept supplying
them with three decommissioned vehicles
every month. It’s a pretty sweet deal:
A crazed car-lover’s paradise, where as long as
you keep it within the walls, anything goes, baby.
But there is one strange little detail. A
question that remains unanswered. Drones sent
in by the Foundation to spy on the residents
of Vulture Gulch have picked up one strange
recurring theme in their chatter: Mentions of an
individual known only as “The Boss” paying them a
visit. And we can only assume they don’t mean
Bruce Springsteen. The only clues we have are
that the Gearheads believe this Boss created them
and put them here on this earth to be totally rad.
The other clue is a seemingly pervasive belief
that, someday soon, the Boss will return.
Who do you think the boss of the
Exploding Zombie Gearheads truly
is? Let us know down in the comments.
Now go check out “Top 15 Most Dangerous
SCP Monsters in Containment” and “Evil
Monster Created by SCP Foundation
SCP-2419 - The Laughing Men”
for more of the biggest bad
boys in Foundation history!